[Chanting] Cancer, asthma. No, no, no.
Toxic gases. No, no, no.
What do we want?  Shut it down.
When do we want it? Now.
We will not stand for environmental
racism because it has become clear to us
that poor people and people of color
continue to be disproportionately
affected by the challenges posed by
these neighborhood drilling sites
that continue to go on.
So, STAND-LA came to us at the beginning
of the school year
and they were specifically interested in
the community of Wilmington.
They had a couple locations where they felt as though these very specific oil companies
were not following rules properly
and that was negatively affecting
the actual community itself.
(health survey)
I didn't know before coming to college that
fracking was even a thing or oil-drilling was a thing.
and they were so prevalent.
But, just after investigating it more
you realize how close they are to residents.
(health survey)
So, we want our research to be the beginning
of talking about it.
She had also throat infections, she has had bronchitis.
We do see some pretty bold differences.
For example, throat infections themselves just in the 50
people that we surveyed,
14 of them in Wilmington versus five in West Pico
versus six in Pacoima.
It raises an eyebrow.
Well for me, since the beginning this was very personal because I come from south central Los Angeles.
Its a low-income people of color community.
So I could relate a lot to the people from Wilmington.
Just being part of this research project has been great because I feel like I'm
making a difference using my education
which is something that I wanted to do.
Through this project, it really empowered
me the same way that it does just being
in environmental science. It's changed my
entire senior year in the way that I
actually am going to end up finishing
UCLA is like so much brighter than it
would have been without it.
Point the people who are going to start doing actual investigation in the right direction.
And hopefully get that moving towards real results
where this community doesn't have to
rely on, you know, am I going to be
sick tomorrow or can I go to work.